Many of us suffered from anxiety symptoms
Whether they are testing or applying for a new job
But some people find it difficult to stop worrying
Even in situations that seem normal, leaving a lasting impact on
Their quality of life, what happens?
Why are they so worried? Nearly seven million people
They have generalized disorder, which means
That they are over-anxious most days, for at least six months
This includes disturbances of sleep, muscle cramps and cramps
Panic episodes may also occur, but their nature varies where they come from
In sudden and short periods of excessive fear that leads to
Severe physical reactions such as accelerated heartbeat, shortness of breath, and dizziness
In fact, anyone who is suffering from a panic attack, whether he has a disorder or not
There may be no specific reason for this panic attack
Although we do not fully understand it, anxiety is partly caused by the amjadala and the hypothalamus, which are responsible for the rotation of cortisol and adrenalin in the body
Genetically, 40 percent of patients with generalized disorder have a relative with the same disease
Which means I am the levels of these hormones you have associated with your genes
Your surroundings may be another factor
Some disorders are associated with traumatic experiences in childhood
The levels of neutron transmitters such as GABA, serotonin, and dopamine have changed
Be another reason. Responsible serotonin hormone
About the sense of well-being and happiness
Works by moving between Neuron and another inside the brain through a difference called "synaps"
Any unused serotonin is returned to the original Neuron by a special carrier
But those with some anxiety disorders such as obsessive-compulsive disorder (OCD)
It has been suggested that a mutation in these vectors doubles the size of serotonin yield
Before arriving at the future Neurons
Which results in a decrease in the amount of the difference "Synapse", and ultimately to affect the emotions
This was the reason for the use of drugs such as selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors (SSRIs)
In cases of these anxieties so that serotonin is prevented from returning to the original neuron
Also, many anxiety disorders show an excessive reaction in the amygdala and the gray environment "periaqueductal gray area"
Resulting in negative effects not only on the brain
But even on our bodies. In a study of nearly 300 people for five years
Those with an overactive amygdala were more likely to develop heart disease
Because the amygdala stimulates the production of white blood cells
In the bone marrow leading
To inflate affects the
Arterial heart artery
If you have a fear of a phobia, this is a form of anxiety disorder
But as many fears help us survive
Such as the fear of spiders or highlands has been suggested that
These fears may be stored in DNA and inherited
When mice are electrocuted after exposure to the smell of a fruit
They quickly learn to fear that smell
But exciting new generations of mice
Also afraid of the same smells of those fruits.
Although the new mice were not subjected to electric shock, it turned out that
Because of the strong reaction of the electric shock in the brain's receptors
Make new generations more sensitive to the same smells
In a manner that suggests that receptors are in the operating mode for those that are odors
These odors are associated with some cases of fear (phobia)
For treatment, cognitive behavior therapy helps
To recognize ideas that stimulate feelings
Affecting the disposition is aimed at
Change these thoughts to wrestle anxiety
On the other hand, drugs such as SRIs and SNRIS
They are used to prevent serotonin or norepryphrine absorption
But may produce side effects and sometimes
Affect negatively with long use
Benzodiazepines are also used to help sleep
Muscle relaxation is also associated with dementia at large generations
It is necessary to know that the basis of nervous and chemical anxiety is very complex
The news of someone who is calm will not come with any result
So we decided to make another video and explained what we were doing
In order to overcome anxiety some tips and tricks that
We think it works. You can see it by clicking here. Subscribe to the weekly scientific videos every Thursday